- [Voiceover] The article
featured the Sea Islands
because many were known there to live
much as their ancestors of a century
ago had lived.
So this one immediately seems strange
because they're saying
the article featured
the Sea Islands because many were known,
so when they're saying
featured the Sea Islands
because many were known, I'm thinking
that when they're saying many were known,
I think they're talking
about the Sea Islands
because that's what the
article was featured on.
Because many were known there to live
much as their ances--
Well islands don't live
much as their ancestors.
So the way this reads it
sounds like, you know,
the article was talking about Sea Islands
because many of the Sea Islands were known
to live like the Sea Islands' ancestors.
Well islands don't have ancestors,
at least in the way that we traditionally
think about it, so this
is just badly phrased.
So I'm going to rule it out as it is.
So I'm going to rule out choice A,
which is the kind of as it is.
So they're really talking about where
the residents were known to live
as their ancestors.
So we have to be a little
bit more specific here.
The article featured the Sea Islands
because they were known for living,
well once again, they,
it's not the Sea Islands.
We're really talking about the residents,
the people of the Sea Islands.
So I'm going to rule this one out as well.
The article featured the Sea Islands
because many of the people there
were known to live much as their ancestors
of a century ago had lived.
Well at least this one's conveying
the right impression.
It's making it clear we're not talking
about the Sea Islands' ancestors,
or the Sea Islands living
like their ancestors,
we're talking about the
people who are known
to live there live like their ancestors.
So this one is feeling pretty good.
Let's try the other choices.
The article featured the Sea Islands
because of the many people,
they were there living
much as their ancestors
of a century ago had lived.
So once again, you have this comma here,
this is convoluted, and it's also
not completely clear.
The article featured the Sea Islands
because of the many people,
they were living.
This makes it sound like the Sea Islands
are somehow a subset of the many people,
and still that they're talking about
the Sea Islands themselves were living
like their ancestors.
Once again, it doesn't make sense,
or at least it's confusing.
So I'm going to rule that one out.
The article featured the Sea Islands
because of knowing that
many people lived there
much as their ancestors of
a century ago had lived.
Well this one has all sorts of problems.
If you said because of
knowing that many people
lived there much as their ancestors
of a century ago had lived,
it leaves you hanging.
Well what was because of knowing
that many people had lived there?
So it leaves you hanging.
It's also just convoluted.
Because of knowing that many people
had lived there much as their ancestors?
Because we know this fact,
something is going to be there
and they didn't even tell us
what is because of knowing?
So this one is also really,
really, really strange.
So definitely like C.
The article featured the Sea Islands
because many of the people there
were known to live much as their ancestors
of a century ago had lived.
Yeah, that's nice and understandable.